Hello and welcome to this video on dynamic nav meshes.
Now, there may be times when you will need your nav mesh to update,
and this is not done by default.
And I'm going to demonstrate that by...
I'm going to grab this blue cube over here,
drag this over, and I'm going to make a couple of changes to it.
The first thing is I don't want to simulate physics for this one,
I'm going to reduce the rotation so that it's flat.
And I'm going to move this out so that it's a bit of a long one.
Now, at the moment, you can see that this does not affect the navigation.
And that is because for this, we have unticked the can ever affect navigation.
If I take that on, you can see that's going to change it
so the navigation is working around it.
Now, I want this to move. So there's a couple of things.
We're already movable, so that's fine.
But I am going to add in a component just here.
And this is going to be the rotating movement component.
And the rotating movement is going to rotate on the z-axis by 180.
And let's just try that one second.
Yes, we can see that that's pretty fast.
So we've got the rotation is moving pretty fast for that.
I'm going to slow it down just a little bit.
So I grab the rotating movement, I'm going to change that to 90.
So that's about half the speed.
Again, if I simulate, we can see that this is updating as we go.
Now, what you'll notice here is as we're running,
this isn't updating the nav mesh at all.
So if I was to actually play when I was in the game,
if I wanted to move to here, I could,
but I can never cross this middle section because navigation is an update.
Oh, this is quite easy to fix.
Again, we have to jump into the project settings.
So if we come up to the top, select project settings and navigation mesh here.
So under navigation mesh, you'll see as we work our way through it,
there is a runtime generation.
So under generation, we have, I'm just going to search for it.
Runtime goes to the top, here you go.
Under the navigation mesh, we have the option for runtime generation.
And if I drop this down, we have a couple of options.
We have dynamic modifier only, and we have the dynamic.
So we're going to use dynamic straight up.
And now that that's ticked, if we simulate, you can see what's going on here.
The nav mesh is updating as we go.
Now you'll also be able to notice that the color of the sections
that are now in red, these are the ones that have to update.
To reduce the load runtime, you don't want to rebuild the entire nav mesh,
especially if you've got quite a big level,
that'd be very, very expensive for every moving object.
So what it does is it will just rebuild the ones where something dynamic has moved in it.
And if I reduced it and I could manage to fit it into a singular one,
I'll just take that down to about four,
you'll see that it's only going to affect this one.
But it's in red because it needs to take time on tick to update this.
OK, and as you probably noticed in the project settings,
there was another option under runtime generation,
and that is dynamic modifiers only.
Let's select that.
So you're in a situation where you do want the nav mesh to update,
but not for every little thing.
For example, these you could run through and knock them out the way.
So if I was to show you at the moment when my character comes over,
you might want to keep it so that they knock them out the way.
And therefore, we wouldn't want these to affect the nav mesh,
but we would want something like this to affect the nav mesh.
So in this case, we can use modifiers only.
So if I jump in to my project settings,
change it to dynamic modifiers only,
the first thing is when I play, you'll notice that nothing updates at all.
Now what I'm going to do is I'm going to add another component
to this rotating movement here,
and I'm going to search for a nav modifier.
OK, now you'd usually do this as part of a blueprint.
So if you created a blueprint for something that revolves,
you would add the modifier into the blueprint
and it would be easier to manage.
But I just want to get across in this demonstration how this works.
Now I am going to change the extents to about 550
so that it kind of matches what we've got there.
And now if we look at that,
you can see that this is updating as we would expect beforehand.
Now there is one problem.
The old nav mesh is below here.
So we've already cut out this area.
And because we're not taking it into consideration,
that's going to stay there sort of indefinitely.
So let's correct that.
What I'm going to do is with the object selected under nav,
I'm going to tick off Can Effect Navigation.
So that means our nav modifier,
which we won't see until we run the game,
is the only thing which is going to affect this navigation.
So if I run, you'll see that that opens.
So that's a sort of opt-in effect.
Navigation is only going to be affected by these nav modifiers.
And these are something that you'd need to add
to the things that you want to change the navigation.
And you would need to...
And it would update it accordingly.
So that is the nav modifier.
And that's the basics of the dynamic nav mesh.
The next thing we'll be looking at is the nav mesh in the vocal.